the girag and experience but as an
individual those jobs almost exist to
let you know that you for sure don't
want to do that it's like the feeling of
it being it's like being a real bad
relationship right like what what gets
you out of a relationship it fucking
explode that's what happens you get to a
certain point we like will you just shut
the fuck up and leave me alone I can't
take it as negativity anymore we're done
we're done here okay we boom but you
have to hit this well you got into the
bottom in order to change yeah and you
got to have that McDonald's job to
appreciate a really good job you're
great to talk about later like you and I
we talk about our first jobs it gave you
the motivation to get out get on your
fucking horse and get out of there yeah
if you didn't have that motivation and
that's where when we're talking about
money like about our society designed to
sort of encourage motivation which
encourages success which encourages
financial rewards encourages more
attractive to the opposite sex when you
drive in a Ferrari to a lot of checks
that's a fact a lot of people get really
mad at that but that's a fact it's just
a fact there's just too many dudes who
are ugly and old who have really hot
wives right I mean it's just fact guys
get billions of dollars in giant yachts
and they're fucking these hot chicks and
doesn't make any sense but that's a fact
no you can't deny that fact why is that
fact exist well it exists because we got
a weird system got a weird system and
that's one of the holes in the system
one of the holes in the system is that
achievement as superseded actual
physical desire for a lot of these poor
gold diggers and they let this wrinkly
old cocksucker shoot his dry loads into
you ah and and you got to pretend you
love it oh maybe oh yeah put him out
baby
why you like that guy who got his face
farted on threw up at nagas
that's what you thinkin that's old man
keeps on you yeah and he doesn't shower
on purpose just to degrade you further
like it's if it's all about the money
yeah what do you suck it now baby well
there's a lot of guys that definitely
have a resentment towards these gold
dealers yeah for sure especially once
the woman's the the fun has worn off of
the game of pretending your attraction
to the man which you know if you're a
guy who's not attractive and you're
successful and you believe in your head
that you're something cool something
special about you look how well I've
done and
this defines me this watch serious
watched a $50,000 watch and this is a
fucking 20 million dollar state and you
get that shit in your head and you get a
girl and she tricks you with your own
ego she can get baby you're just amazing
to be around I'm just so lucky we met
each other meanwhile she is perfect her
tits or just melons bobbing gently and
his really strange thin material clothes
that she wears that clings of her hips
and just inches lower than her vagina
just hanging inches lower than image on
her bubble ass and perfect legs gap
under the kissing hose yo Jesus Christ
and she just strokes your cock kisses
you and you're like I'm marrying this
bitch
wait a Manby yes yes yes hi she's like
tired she's the high so she gives that
shoulder run oh yeah and that's the
thing as you realize with her not only
am I getting the fucking body I'm
getting shoulder rubs I'm getting
subservient the bitch can cook how she
treats the help well she gets it and you
can go out with her and she knows how to
treat your friends yeah she knows how to
kiss you when frozen's you in your sleep
because she realizes that she's tricked
you into having a shitty will where she
gets everything because your kids are
that you're she convinced you the kids
would be better off if you didn't give
them a safety net because that would
make them successful like you so she
played to your ego and you cut the kids
out of the will and gave all the money
is crazy tie bitch who stop slowly
poisoning your drink and she won she
earned it that's the thing about like
Anna Nicole Smith when his fucking
stupid kids wanted a state no Anna
Nicole was sucking his dick didn't you
stew a bit about this yeah fuck yeah
yeah it's like closers night was it was
the whole thing about them saying like
oh my god she's taking advantage of him
she's only being she's only with him for
his money I'm like don't you think he
fucking down right like I made a billion
dollars from scratch
chances are he's a tad crafty and it was
like this whole thing about like how do
you want to die you'd want to die
shaking and alone in your hospital bed
surrounded by loved ones or you want to
get a big fat Kentucky Fried hooker and
just blow it out that's it did and it
was all him dying telling her to lick
his ass well therefore shit he did to
her right before he died and the kids
have got nothing
and they deserve you were raised with
all that fucking money you went to
private schools you had tennis coaches
he probably bought you houses why do you
need more what the fuck did you do you
didn't suck his dick yeah you need to
get your own money stupid right you rode
the ride and now it's over and I think
also this sounds fucked up but that
exists because it's a predatory
situation you're prey you know if you're
a vulnerable old weak emotional guy who
also has a billion dollars we weren't
going to prey on you they're going to
pretend to be something they're not and
they might even convince themselves that
they are that something that they're
pretending to be because their instinct
to try to acquire your wealth and your
social status is so strong that they
want to be the Trump girl they want to
be the new girl the Trump leaves his
wife for ya I don't think it's black and
white I mean if you're a woman that grew
up in that paradigm maybe your dad had
money and your mother was a stay-at-home
mom and maybe she had a hint of that and
then all sudden you're involved in
charitable organizations and you're
taking his wealth and you're channeling
into positive things so you see it
starts to not necessarily be about is he
the one I would have married just based
on his looks and charisma but it starts
to become about like well life is
pairing up with somebody and being
powerful like you watch house of cards
no I haven't don't don't you fucking
spoiler alert just to say the
relationship is about power I know that
movie that show brother is supposed to
be amazing it says me jumping onto it
next but it's basically about how a
couple can be together because they're a
power couple
and it's interesting Bill and Hillary
most likely right most likely absolutely
mum most presidents I think probably you
have to be I don't think you can do that
thing on your own I think that's a nutty
fucking job and the first lady has a
prominent role in our culture and she's
constantly speaking and doing these
things and III think you're dead right I
think you're dead right about that I
think it's also that we're also talking
about just two stops on a broad range of
possibilities from ultimately totally
evil Russian hot prostitute who steals
your organs when you're asleep at 2:00
someone who just doesn't want to work
and the guys kind of cool and he treats
her good and so she stays with them yeah
you know I've seen both I've seen both
I've seen I've seen people get
victimized and I've seen people that are
just in sort of these relationship where
I wouldn't want it but it works for them
you know sometimes they're out the other
women the woman will tease and be like
yeah uh-huh nice at you know I wouldn't
be with you if it wasn't for the fucking
money
oh it's not even a teeny because of
course I know that that's a movie that's
in a movie what was the movie that was
in there was a movie that was in where
the tune well no the what Schindler's
List terms of endearment
get it would help it you do it right
away chitty-chitty go right to fucking
platoon and the picture and organs
hanging out on on the beach um I forget
the movie man
but it was just about about a guy who
lost everything and in the scene like
his wife was like laughing about it when
everything was going great and then when
he did lose all the money she did
fucking leave them Hey
well actually was in the wolf of
wallstreet - it's a common theme in the
wolf of Wall Street obviously it was a
crazy coked up fucking maniac piece of
shit but when he was going under and his
business was going on it that's when the
wife left when he was doing great
the wife wanted him when he was married
to another woman I mean it's like it was
it was a classic story so it's not like
that's an unfamiliar paradigm to us its
nature it's a wounded antelope that gets
taken out by the the lion
it's she needs somebody to provide for
her or she doesn't
but in that role she does if she chooses
that role if she chooses the role of
fucking the old Greek Lee shaky man with
his fucking pale translucent dick that
he sticks inside we could see as he's
coming could see the veins like pop
whatever blood of God and it's like a
little highway going down his fucking
saran-wrap skin filled with Viagra yeah
and just shooting dust bubbles into her
pussy yeah yeah man I mean that's taking
her you Cannell's you can take that
choice or you know you could start an
art gallery and become a
multimillionaire on your own I mean you
could do that too okay it's but when you
are that girl okay if you are that 25
year old girl and Adderall problem
that's looking to try to hook up with
some old billionaire dude and marry
him so he'd be taken care of for life
your that but that's your role that's
what you've chosen you might have more
potential than that that doesn't mean
that that's not what you've chosen oh
you don't even know baby she's so slick
she's so smart I mean that is one of the
smartest girls I've ever met in my life
when she met him and she put off it
doesn't matter are you talking nonsense
she's still that girl she's promised
that you can't say no no listen you
can't say she's a prostitute good I know
her and she's powerful and what she did
was yeah she's really clever and she
figured out way to maybe like guys no no
she's still prostitute right you're
missing the whole point right it doesn't
matter if she has all those potential
she beats 150 books a week okay don't
fucking tell me that girl is so goddamn
smart oh my god you're saying she's not
smart go see she's a hooker
all right she's playing the role of a
hooker this was the opposite in terms of
a female on a male because sometimes
women are so hot that the guy is getting
something out of her and he's putting up
with not not having love not having
respect for her but wanting that pussy
so bad or that status of being with
somebody that's that hot that in the
same way he's a prostitute for what he's
getting from her oh yeah they're
certainly mean there's exchanges other
than money that are unfair the reason
the old man gets the girl in the first
place is because of his fucking money
that's it so it's honest if Oh people
know what they're getting sort of but
it's not because they're playing a game
called love in the game is baby I love
you I'm just so happy to be with you oh
you love me oh come on you want some
dick they lot they're playing a game
somebody wins a show is a winner or
loser and he gets pussy unless you
should try the pussy is she drugs him
it's prank
well it's a matter about maintaining
that relationship and this allowing her
to fuck her personal trainer she's going
to share ok she's going to look how hot
she is she's got this little waist this
dynamic body she's 25 years old here 90
she's gonna fuck her trainer
just accept it be happy that you could
fucker and don't ask questions
pretty girl this is he's supposed to
work that early is out open those with
just a smile yeah rich old man she won't
have to worry it's fucking great Eagle
song man yeah that's right I can't hide
your lyin eyes man it's fucking Jam
see if it's something hard for you
because when you met your wife you were
already very successful you had money uh
me I had my girl I fucked up because I
was single when I met my girl my now
wife is lucky I had an MTV game shell
and I was like I met her at the wrong
fucking time I coulda lined up so much
but that's not true because you you
enjoyed it see everybody's worried about
it but you still do but everybody's
worried about what they didn't do all
right this is no I should have done this
no you shouldn't have traffic I've had
people in my life to tell me the most
important thing that ever happened to
them was fuckin up because if you fuck
up then you realize you fucked up and
that's what motivates you to get away
from McDonald this is how I should have
never done that of course you should
have done it yeah I lost everything I
fucked up getting that marriage man you
should've fucking got married you should
have lost everything now you know right
you win now you win you got the
knowledge don't ever let it happen again
don't use it as an excuse to just wallow
in your own sins nothing worse than the
wallowing fucking deforest guy you know
he's living in a condo and in Marina del
Rey and he's fucking go to the same bar
every night the same stuff he's one of
those guys were like the woman at
Starbucks knows his name because his
life has become so simplified and dumbed
down because he's afraid to move forward
after a divorce Eddie Bravo used to be a
DJ a strip club when we first met and
Eddie introduced me to the game of how
these girls would go about getting men
to buy them things like I'd be friends
with his girl I knew him through him so
they were like there were nice people
you know and I'd have relationships with
him so I was just talking to them they
would tell me about these guys that they
were hooking up with that would buy them
cars and shit and how they would do it
so I visited him at work and I'm like
what's going on man and he's like
nothing dude check this out
you're gonna talk to this girl and then
hurt one of her clients when she comes
in like you got you got to see like this
guy just bought her a truck he bought
her like a Yukon Denali and so the girls
hanging out and you know hanging out
with their friends and this guy comes in
who was there's a classic story he's a
wounded gazelle 55 year old divorce guy
works at the post office coming in with
his postal jacket on okay
he's no armed from
here he bought her a $35,000 car man in
this guy he bought her a fucking Yukon
Denali you know it was a nice car maybe
$35,000 the wrong number I'm just
throwing it out there whatever it is he
bought her a new car so um she sees him
and she goes oh my god and she runs over
like little baby steps like a girl and
she's fucking naked man she's naked
she's in her underwear she's got a
bikini on and she goes over and gives
this guy a hug and you could see this
guy is defenseless there's no way in the
world that a girl that looks like that
would ever have that kind of reaction to
him so he's got to pay for that you got
to pay for that you got to pay for it by
buying her car or taking care of her
fucking credit problem that she's got or
you know do whatever you got to figure
out how to pay for that shit because
there's no other way that you're gonna
get that relationship but when I watched
it I was like I looked at Eddie and he
was like that shit straight mercenary
right and I was like this is crazy like
they just they put a con game on these
guys well I got a friend who's like he
seems to like make friends with rich
people and he's a good guy but it's
weird and he says that a few of these
guys they really do take care of girls
they've got like an apartment in New
York that she lives in she gets a check
every month
I mean figure it cost them 50 grand a
year and these are guys that have
fucking 30 million dollars so to have a
relationship set up when when they come
to town they don't have to call an
escort service and they don't have to go
out and try to make a straight
relationship where they have to send
flowers and call every day they come to
town she's fucking gorgeous Pat you know
powerful confident it's all on the table
and they've got like three cities set up
and it's and when when he comes to town
she is available 24/7 whatever the fuck
he wants and I bet they have some kind
of friendship underneath it all maybe
not well that would be great if it all
worked out like that right if that was
the arrangement and it all worked out
like that right but the problem with
people is there's no there's never
really a static state maintains itself
for any long periods of time when it
comes to relationships you either kind
of all in or you drift in and out of
each other or she finds another guy I
mean people were weird they
it's very difficult to me so how are you
going to maintain a long-term
prostitution elationship right you're
not most likely people that begin with
yeah most likely I mean you're painted
out to be awesome and beautiful but the
reality is that's not what the girl
wants she wants to find a guy either if
she wants someone to take care of her
she wants to find a guy to take care of
her and I need her lover and her
boyfriend or her husband or whatever and
for the this guy that thinks that he's
gonna like maintain you're gonna have to
match each one of these situations if
you're some crazy CEO of some giant
corporation you got like four apartments
scattered out across the country with
chicks living in them you're gonna
maintain these positions like who's
who's fucking her when you're not there
what's happening is anybody plotting
your death you better be sure you know
dude what did you sign you start
anything crazy you know does she have
any photographs your dick like we get
for a credit card yeah yeah did you give
her a credit card well it's like you'd
have to monitor these situations this
ain't gonna be a normal person it's
gonna be a person's willing to fuck you
because you pay for that right and you
know they might be crazy yeah easily
might be crazy I heard this dude I was
at the W and sitting in the lobby
waiting and this dude sitting next mean
he's got an accent sounds Scandinavian
and he's going on Oh fine I got you on
the phone you've been so hard to reach
lately baby I you know you know I I I'm
so crazy but you're so beautiful I can't
wait to get you out you need to stop
going to college you come I take care of
he'd never met her and he was talking on
the phone clearly met on some kind of
high-end dating service where you get
women that you take care of yeah she was
flirting back and they were making plans
for her to fly out for a week he was
going to take her to the best
restaurants in LA blah blah I was
telling her all the things he's gonna
bribe her with right and he has seen
pictures online they had talked on the
phone clearly a few times and he was
closing he was making the arrangements
to fly her out okay why do we have a
problem dot why does anybody have a
probably don't think anyone should have
this shipment right she's a real nothing
wrong one's eyes are open I don't think
I think all prostitution should be
legalized I think that whorehouses
should be legalized I think that having
having horrors on the street or having
to go through Craigslist is it's
horrible the reality is people are going
to use whores mm put it on the table
legalize it make them get tested for for
STDs make sure they're keeping their
money they're not getting fucking beaten
up
and and relationships like this should
be fine
yeah well it'sit's unbelievably
fascinating that you have something that
everybody wants and everybody gets for
free but as soon as you attach money to
it it has this massive stigma to it like
you know saying that you these
prostitution relationships aren't stable
what relationships are you know our if
you you hook up with someone is that
going to be stable if you just meet
people randomly and have sex let me
agree to have sex with each other is
that gonna be stable you sure it might
not be stable either
you might run into instability
everywhere you turn but the main reason
why we have all these negativity
negative ideas attached to the idea of
prostitution is because it's illegal
what if you hook up one night with a
check you bought dinner you bought
drinks you paid for the cab back to the
apartment you spent all the money you
guys fuck how is that different than how
many things are all money and having sex
with her how about all those things are
just you dating and there's nothing
wrong with being nice and being nice to
someone taking a friend out or driving
them around taking them to a nice
restaurant nothing wrong with that
but then what if she says I've got the
situation um I'm three months hurt in my
rent and I don't know what's doing you
look I'll just take care of it right and
you write her a check and then she sucks
your dick what happened there right what
happened there
did you pay for her to suck your dick we
don't know she might have sucked your
dick anyway you know I might have been
like listen baby you know you don't get
money from me but you do get dick and
you put your dick out and she blows you
that's different right but most guys
can't pull that off what about what
about a marriage where the wife does not
work has never earned a dime she's
having sex with you mm-hmm that's
prostitution according to some people
according to some people certainly is I
mean according to a lot of male
feminists it would be right all right
yeah I mean it's it's money coming in
though with the sex going out I mean if
that's where you want to look at but
it's agreement it's the problem is the
idea of money its agreements you that's
where the idea of prostitution sort of
it comes down to what it comes down to
is are people having sex with people
that they might not necessarily have
been willing to without any benefit but
that benefit exists so they are willing
to do it is that prostitution because if
it if that benefit is only money then
you're you're defining sex for something
as sex for money that's prostitution but
everything is sex
if you see it like you were talking
about the Ferrari thing before if you're
at a club and you see a guy pull up in a
Ferrari and you go home with that guy
part of the reason you went home with
him is you saw the Ferrari there's not
dollars exchanged but there's an
implicit understanding this dude's got
money and he spends it like a fucking
lunatic
yep and you want to be around that
that's a good point that he spends it
like a fucking lunatic that's a great
point because that's really what it is a
guy who's so flashy he's driving a
$250,000 car he's not gonna hesitate to
give you a couple grand here and there
right you know you want to buy a new
pair of shoes he's like here fucking
peels off some hundreds right gives you
a kiss on the cheek and goes back to
doing business buy sell buy sell this is
the fucking some crazy right
multi-millionaire maniac banker dude
right Byron it's a party and you just
got invited you're gonna be a regular
party this guy who doesn't give a shit
about money he knows he's gonna die soon
because he's on adderall and he's
chain-smoke and he's a drunk and
wherever you go you're eating the best
steaks you're getting the best clubs
life is fucking good oh yeah oh yeah and
I'm fucking him yeah yeah you're very
little Evans wife and every when you
show up the country club Oh mrs. nickel
Evan please come on in
and you've got a little poodle with you
and you fucking walk in your $3,000
shoes and yeah you waddle in there and
take your tennis lesson your tennis
player fucking bones you in the locker
room he knows it then the husband says
bring them over I want to watch oh Jesus
thank that's ugly a lot of guys won't do
that Brett I don't think that's a normal
thing no I don't think that's a watching
wanna watch that's a weird thing and
then the cuckold porn mmm just lets you
know chuckle poor where do you find that
I really don't want a pin cuckold porn
don't do it Brian
you